[Music]
welcome back to health record where we
talk about what happens
whatever we want hello
what's up mike
dude
just trying to hire some hotties you
know yeah that's one of the advice i got
from the group here is that the only way
to run a successful business is hotties
that's business 101. you don't choose
good looking people to work for your
business uh that uh so we don't really
have any employees uh currently um but
that is isn't that like a little survey
thing that people get all upset about
like two people
same qualifications the better looking
one gets hired 80 of the time or some
[ __ ] that happens in nature too that's
what i'm saying like i'm not saying it's
bad you have two birds that show up and
they go hey we both made nests but then
the hotter birds don't get [ __ ] by the
other damn hot but you know how like
bird sex works i do i do i do i do
indeed how does that how does it work
superficial they don't move the feathers
out and the penis come out
they go yeah it's chicken babies every
time now what does a bird penis look
like
it's kind of like a beak
lower beak hey i don't know if this is
true or not but to me i'm like this is
true i studied i think we're
generalizing all birds yeah hey bird's
got we got beaks for kicks
birthdays
i've never seen a bird dick before
look up a duck look up a duck a duck
there's something a duck dick is a nasty
duck dicks are with the uh claw right
hey the ducks are [ __ ] [ __ ] man
it has a clown duck dick is [ __ ] it
looks like a monster i think duck sex is
raped bro they're rapey yeah yeah it's a
gang bang that's what it is
is that wall street journal
you got to pay the full nat geo
subscription what is that
this guy's good at making businesses man
you're really good at this this is how i
uh what i thought it would yeah bart
started to
describe dick
[Laughter]
it's only two dollars that's pretty
cheap that's the dollar ninety-eight
all the expressions it's too much
yeah you gotta spice up what you wanted
to see yeah i don't know either but i
think it's right
a guy shows up in your gym wearing that
to work out
is he oh is that easy allowed you guys
want a
medium to long story yeah so i opened a
gym in 2010 more like a training
facility and i was broke i was in junior
college and saw
craigslist hunting like a mother to get
this equipment and there was a gym in
san francisco which i don't know how
it's legal but i believe it was an all
men's gym
um you could do that you could do old
trick gyms it's called a gentleman's
club uh no it was it was it was like a
bodybuilding-ish all men's gym and i'm
gonna go get these dumbbells so i run a
u-haul and i go down there and this
place is closing down and uh it's in a
certain district in san francisco i know
you're talking i love certain districts
the fabric doesn't love certain
what's the bird's penis
oh that thing is heavy
i'm telling you when you move the
feathers yeah it's really amazing
they're very hot it's really in there
so so we first go in there and there's
like nobody there so i start kind of
looking around um and there's very odd
art on the wall there's like a you know
like a very um is it similar to that uh
honestly so it's like the the famous
arnold schwarzenegger double bicep but
some things have been photoshopped oh
it's been doctored like these birds
and so then i'm looking around the
financial district i think it was like
the terminator dwarf it was fisherman's
waterline yeah yeah is it the terminator
with a hard dick so it was it was uh
bodybuilding uh bodybuilding yeah arnold
with a [ __ ] photoshopped on top of his
posing oh wow so then i'm looking around
trying to meet the guy whoever's
supposed to give me you know exchange
money grab these dumbbells and get out
of here and i turn the corner and
there's a i'd say 65 year old gentleman
and similar to that bird
wife beater chopped off
boots
just doing curls in the corner all by
himself staring at you no just staring
at the wall just working out his dick
was actually out he was in like um like
a thong a mankini of nature's yeah
banana hammock yeah interesting
and did you say excuse me sir are you
done with that
can i can i work in
how many sets you got left
so he's working out while like there's
no one else in the place people are just
taking the equipment out then right
there's not a soul in the place and yeah
they're just like on a on a closing sale
and i grabbed my dumbbells and i went
out i almost bought that order because
he was the only guy that was the member
yeah probably
yeah i wanted that arnold poster but i
just looked up his arnold hung i don't
know it doesn't say anything i don't
know if that's what we should be
googling
that's on your record forever if you do
that yeah but what do you think you
think he is i think you know i i think
he i think he was but then he probably
[ __ ] up with steroids i don't think he
does your pee pee just your the balls
yeah he's not your tie now what what do
you think of the height thing right like
i remember being in high school and
every girl and even still it's like a
joke like every girl wants to do like a
six six dude like well if he's six
sticks you gotta have a big dick right i
think i think the chances are in your
favor because it's like feeder hands
look look at look at steve bro let's not
know how far i'm six four and a half six
four dude so steve has this dude's got a
dog bro he has a big head just hung out
like that like that duck look at his
face
i don't know
but i've also taken showers like 80
dudes at a time
and uh they're unrelated do you think
completely by your by your anecdotal
80-person survey that's a lot of people
no it's an okay for a survey if we're
talking science sometimes we switch
showers and i just check out the other
80 dudes and same thing it's just random
you think it's it's very but then i
guess they're not also erect
that's true i don't know i don't know if
they're growers i don't know if they're
growers i think tall guys are more
likely to be growers what do you think
steve
yeah steve no i don't know what tall
guys are more likely to be growers i
think so what's the science behind that
i don't know man this is just a gut
feeling
feeling is always right
look at this bro
he's connected
that's kind of messed up because then
you're saying
well you know
uh he could be it's probably bigger than
mine how old is his house
huh 18 or something he's 18 yeah he's
got the same bro you know messi lionel
messi has the same disease that he does
what uh they gave him hgh when he was in
high school and that's all you need to
i didn't know messi had that but i do
know they gave me it's like uh
i don't know what it is pituitary gland
because like when you you get past a
certain age you need the testosterone or
whatever or the gland doesn't produce
enough testosterone and then it doesn't
i saw this one porno where the little
dude
was like
he had a big-ass dick dude yeah was he
all like light-headed he was all
light-headed and [ __ ] i think it's all
right it looked like
it looked like a magnet don't look like
he's just like he's like does a 64 dude
have the same size hard as a 560.
because if that's the case then i would
say it's like that i think it's
unrelated that's why some people have
like uh they don't really have good
cardio or they do because their lungs or
hearts big or whatever i mean like girls
right they could be tall short whatever
but their tit size are different
that's true that's so proportionate
it's genetic as [ __ ] everything's
genetic basically
yeah
if only we could fake dick genetics dude
you get a big dick energy bro oh thanks
man they could probably change that now
they can change like babies eye color
and [ __ ] you can probably choose your
kids big size i guess but what if it
doesn't what is it
what if it would if big dick school out
of style though i think i think all
things go out of style i don't think
that one's going out of style they
probably won't well the renaissance it
was the little dicks were in style
that's all the doctors got a little
different i'm gonna go back to the
renaissance
to the male artists drawing them they're
out of style to the girls getting tapped
probably not to the greek to the greeks
it was out of style
they liked little dicks
very very little dicks well they like
fat people too because they mean money
didn't the spartans keep a group of boys
with them so that they could [ __ ]
barnes were pretty good how does that
how does that story work
say that again like even on the
battlefield they wanted to [ __ ] and they
were horny and they had these little
squire boys and [ __ ] i don't know if it
was that i thought they banged squires
to uh make uh teamwork like like bond
yeah no but you know well you're on the
battlefield you need to [ __ ] that bad
age
[Laughter]
when you become a certain age they send
you to boot camp and then you get
stripped away from your family and then
from there you have a bunk mate and then
they encouraged
male on male love they encouraged it
highly so that you fall in love with
your bunkmate and then you spend like 10
years together as like battle buddies
because when you form a line
the guy that's next to you is your bunk
mate hey we should be battle buddies
guys so it's like forged
sexual history
battle buddy up trying to battle buddies
honey it's nothing
babe come on it's business my battle
buddy you want me to die out there yeah
you ain't on the warfield with me we
gotta create a bond babe wartime bonding
on my back you know what you're saying
but after a few years start getting into
those fights
you're like you don't respect my love
language
this is lovely you're doing entj
it only works in the first six months
yeah that's true man we gotta find
knowing you're an extrovert you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
she has switch gotta switch battle
buddies around they got a lot of battle
but there's a network of battle buddies
and they're all each other's battle
buddies you know they're always [ __ ]
each other yeah you have to bart said he
had 80.
[Laughter]
80 battle buddies and then he found
another group of 80. dude there's 160 to
win the war man spartan warriors man
spartan warriors
today's video is brought to you by
curology big shout out to curology by
the way because for all of my life
i was a disgusting child and i did not
believe in using soap products on my
face and it was sweet it was really
weird too because i would use cell
products to wash my hands to wash my
hair my ass and my butthole but when it
came to my face i didn't want to use
anything i was super stubborn i had a
greasy face i had a lot of weird things
happening pimples whatever but i didn't
do absolutely anything to take care of
this wonderful money maker what i like
about curology is sometimes you go to
the store and there's aisles and aisles
of all kinds of face washes and lotions
and moisturizers and it's kind of
intimidating because you're like okay i
don't even know what this chemical means
or what that means or whatever and
what's cool about curology is they have
licensed providers so you just pick what
you want to happen like what are your
skin goals you want to get rid of acne
dark spots scars what do you want to do
and they hook you up with the formula so
you don't have to decide for what all
these chemicals mean for yourself you
just put down what you want to happen
and it's a super super simple routine
they have a face wash in the packet
along with your special customized
formula and the moisturizer to go after
so it's an all-in-one kit that's
directly delivered to your door so you
don't have to go to the store it makes
it even easier so if you're ready to
clean up your skin routine make your
skin glowing and healthy and better go
check out curology.com off the record to
unlock your free
30-day trial it's a whole month a lot
could happen in a whole month you just
have to pay for shipping and handling
which is about five bucks so go to
curology.com off the record to unlock
your free 30-day trial and pay for
shipping and handling thank you very
much thank you they had a weird ritual
where like the girls when it was time to
like their wedding night or whatever
the guys basically got so used to doing
it with other guys
that um the girls had to cut their hair
off and then put on like a guy's outfit
so they couldn't do it you're kidding me
damn like demi moore their hair off yeah
that was a pretty
i mean if it was demi moore oh for sure
yeah where did they discover the history
the inscriptions of these events tablets
yeah someone [ __ ] all right make sure
everybody knows
people gotta hear about the hair
i think they had pens at this point
maybe i'm not it's in my mind it's
better
yeah i like that better but hey no ink
is going to last that [ __ ] long yeah
in real life
hey dude hey poseiros we have pens
they have sword shields catapults but
they don't have pens yet yeah running
water
they don't ride on stuff dog
there's no documents that needs to be
made you know do they have a notary back
then no no
who knows you gotta witness that [ __ ]
they're using clay tablets man
that's like the uh the theory
about like our comic books or our books
three hundred five hundred years from
now people think that's our reality yeah
or mythology
or not evolution
how would they know
oh 500 years that superman wasn't a dude
now oh yeah and like that was our jesus
christ because we wrote all these books
and movies about superman our
superheroes can beat the [ __ ] out of
their superheroes bro oh [ __ ] i don't
know we're reusing their [ __ ] that's
true aquaman's got damn poseidon we got
four yeah that's all nordstrom
is thor that's what i mean yeah we're
just reusing their ass
so [ __ ] party forward
oh [ __ ] never thought of that so
unoriginal thor is based
batman beats everybody dude how come the
other gods didn't throw back like come
come come back to the future like we
only got thor loki odin
oh yeah but those are the norse gods
right like well what about the hercules
tv show in the 90s that's pretty good
kevin starbucks dude kevin sorbo
he was dude he was so kind of jacked but
not quite yeah he was tan though he was
interestingly jacked yeah yeah you have
like long hair balling at the same time
it was like thinning hair but long hair
they should have had like very thin
fabio he would have been better for hell
yeah dude
he was remember all those those novels
that you would see at like uh the crown
books
yeah the grocery store check out counter
the daniel steal [ __ ] yeah that dude is
just on a horse just jacked bro i bet he
makes a lot of money off those what was
his job so i think he's a cover model
yeah being a hot guy yeah some of them
there are weird pictures because they're
like like half painted or they put a
filter on there or something to make it
like fake look like it was a painting
with like [ __ ] acrylic paint it was a
normal picture yeah it was weird and
weird style but the cover would bump up
yeah was it both catching on the specs
yeah do the contours of this i would try
to read through it and i didn't you
tried it i was at a hole in the wall
sushi spot in la like two years ago and
fabio was he walked in the real one you
know the real deal followed
does he still look the way that he looks
like fabio but like he melted a little
bit for sure but he was like good
looking dude still i thought getting an
accident where like some something
burned his face or something no hair or
something his hair yeah something
happened to him
someone [ __ ] up and like his hair cut
fires i'm sure he'd be all right he'll
grow back
good looking dude i'm talking about his
face i'll be like put a hair yeah
books probably made okay money then so
like he might have made or he made some
chips right he was on all the books yeah
was it really fabulous or was it just
the guy who looks like fabio i'm pretty
sure it was fabio dude because it's just
a bunch of gaston looking dudes yeah
yeah fabio was like the answer key of
like ideal man just thinks every guy
who's on those horses nah bro all those
white guys look the same
he was on all the posters on my room too
like
it was everywhere bro my mom bought me
all the fabio posters because what was
fabio in other than commercials
i can't believe it's not butter yeah i
think that's a good guy was he actually
i think it was a book guy i don't know
where he's a book cover guy that's what
he was yeah what made him famous he was
the spokesman for the butter the butter
thing remember i remember watching mtv
cribs on them and i'm like dancing's
balling what is what is his jaw the
books dog it must have oh dude i can't
believe it's not butter
is his main gig this is main game that
was his first like big uh product place
because he must have made it before
all those he was in a a a tv series
called acapulco heat
and the role of claudia highly renowned
he was then he was then in calendars
he had a fragrance campaign buy from us
versace hey that's a merch man and then
he got the i can't believe it's not
butter so he was never on romance novel
however
he's on romance
he was in the tv show called acapulco
acapulco heating up
uncultured swine
soap operas always had hot girls though
i think they're still going on really oh
yeah strong they're still going on weird
fact do you know novellas those mexican
soap operas are super popular in africa
they're also popular in my household
so
another fun fact
your wife watches them uh she she wants
me to learn spanish watching them so we
watch like two or three of them
all the girls are hot
we were watching this one it was like
yeah it was all dudes not funny bunch of
fabios and
or something
is it good did you think you learned
spanish like that yeah it's really good
it's a really good show though i just i
don't like anything with a cartel cartel
scares a [ __ ] at me bro i'm out that's
what they saw when the cartel gets
defeated anything you're watching ah it
makes me feel like they're still around
too fictional too fictional like now
this thing really wait well you don't
like it
i don't i understand not liking cartel
in real life but like shows yeah
that's like a scary you don't like scary
movies like that nope i don't like scary
movies i kind of like that too i don't
like [ __ ] that's real yeah like ghosts
bro ghosts
like like scary [ __ ] that's like very
possible
like my neighbor could be cartel or
something yeah bro we didn't like the
tiger king
i never watched there's some hot weather
ladies wow thanks this is what we've
been waiting for this is janette garcia
oh she's she's a famous one very famous
hot weather lady very famous not exactly
doing the weather on that one is she
she's always getting it wrong though
will she she gets around she's erroneous
she gets her she gets it wrong she gets
a raise
no one cares though they're like nobody
gives two shits
someone did a compilation of her just
turning every single time mm-hmm to do
that
what a genius idea though huh to like
get views on there it's so smart like it
makes so much sense it's like 200
degrees that's why newsletters are
working 200 degrees
they're like damn our ratings go up
every time we talk about the weather
so it becomes the weather channel and
only they do it like over here we try to
[ __ ] hide it her segment's like 30
minutes long that's it right why not the
news is like two minutes tell us the
weather the whole world in tokyo
the weather station and like weather
reports would be dead by now i mean
we've got iphones literally yeah who
actually cares except for the oldest
people ever who died with their tv yeah
they died with the tv still on
those people like i remember as a kid
look in the newspaper like going to
school like oh well do i got to wear a
hoodie today or not yeah dude you would
say something you don't want to be cold
i watched children's mom watching the
weather and i get why they have it
though because she watches it like it's
a basketball game because she's like
the star and the storm comes down the
northwest yeah they do and then you see
her like kind of like
she's making circles it stops right at
la and it heads towards the east here's
the cold wave
got the drama it's got the drama
let's go
they explain it like it's a [ __ ]
basketball game so it's missing the
drama
[Music]
[Music]
you